everybody welcome back to the planet
coaster ski resort a series that I'm
still kind of surprised a decently
sizable section of my audience wants to
watch at all but honestly I'm very glad
because I want to do this thing and
there's some people are into it so hey
that's pretty nice
today's episode is all about building a
restaurants although not quite in the
location that some of you have been
recommending me I've seen some comments
of people recommending to build a
restaurant on top of the mountain as
well as down in the valley to create a
sort of village in the valley but to be
honest all the way since the beginning
I've been planning to have a restaurant
on this section kind of halfway down the
mountain with a view over the different
hills which is something that at least
in my experience in Austria when the
slopes are located on places that are
usually farms in summer you get all of
these houses around the slopes as well
and every now and then you'll have a
restaurant down the middle of the
mountain as well with usually a nice
area in front of it for well be at
après-ski or just in general sitting in
the Sun which is surprisingly nice
honestly in even the cold harsh weather
of a ski resorts especially when you're
clothed in all of your skiing outfits it
can actually be quite nice to just sit
in the Sun for a while so this is gonna
be one of those terraces I'd say and
there's not really a particular
inspiration to this but on the last
video somebody commented recommending me
at a specific restaurant that's located
on the Horace Oliver mountain in Austria
which I thought was super interesting
because it's actually a place that I've
been to myself
and while these kinds of restaurants are
super awesome right on the peak of a
mountain I don't think I really have the
space for it on either of the peaks on
this map so this location is the next
best thing I figured as well so here I'm
just kind of shaping out what the
terrace in front of the building is
going to be like so we have this sort of
manmade structure of wood and stone
sticking out it's to provide this
straight plateau which the terrorists
can be built on and just behind that I'm
going to build the bill
itself and before I get into that into
the build if you will it's something
that's kind of interesting about this
build I think is that I'm taking a
slightly different approach when it
comes to building it because the the
architecture is going to be very similar
to what I've done on this series before
but also on Jaeger horn I'm still
generally following the architecture of
Swiss Chalet style architecture so lots
of wooden beams large overhanging roofs
with very big eaves and things like this
I'll definitely get into the specifics
in a minute because I'm gonna start
building any second now but it's
something to consider I wanted to add a
little bit of variation at least in
terms of how these videos go so for
today's build I'm gonna try to build
this building more in a sense that you
would usually see them built in real
life to really try and replicate the
wooden frames so before I built the
building itself I'm going to build the
structural foundation which everything
is going to rest on so I'm starting out
with a bunch of woodwork this little bit
of wall here is really only to shape out
the size and composition of the building
as its eventually going to be but I'm
just gonna stick to woodwork for the
rest of it and when it comes to the
actual structure this is something which
I've honestly never actually looked into
but I did for this video because I was
always curious if there were specific
terms for this because I've always based
my wooden structural work on real-life
structures but never really knew too
much about the terminology of it so this
type of structure is apparently called a
king post roof given the fact that you
have a horizontal tie beam between the
diagonal struts and then in the middle
of that tie beam you have a vertical
beam going down the middle of the of the
gable roof and this is what is
apparently called a king post and just
next to that you have two diagonal cross
ties as well some struts connecting to
the roof but this is just one of the
many different structures that you can
support such a wooden roof with there
are different sort of shapes for it as
well and which I've definitely gotten
into with some of my builds but this is
probably the most simple one and
most common one some other alternatives
have definitely popped up throughout
Jaeger horn but there's that's too much
detail for me to go into right now
anyway I thought it was interesting
because it's definitely not the first
time that I've built this kind of roof
but it's the first time that I've
learned that apparently it has a very
specific name then I wasn't aware of now
on top of these the this horizontal tie
beam and the vertical kingpost are a big
row of very densely packed rafters or
also known as top cords which are all of
these wooden beams that the roof itself
is going to lie directly on and then
right in the middle on top of the roof
is a ridge board as opposed to having a
roof tile bridge or something like this
so it's it's all wood and it's all
almost exactly the same beam but by
placing it in different directions and
connecting it in different ways I think
you can honestly create quite a
well-shaped wooden basic structure for
any building in planet coaster and
honestly it's kind of something that I
miss in Planet Sue as well because going
back to planet coaster even though there
are so many downsides to it planet Zoo
is difficult to come back from because
the graphics and everything just looks
so much better and the game is honestly
very well optimized compared to planet
coaster as well but at the same time
planet coaster is all these different
wooden textures that allow you to make
so many combinations that really give a
lot of detail and nuance to wooden
buildings which I think why is why I
like building wooden buildings is so
much in planet coaster because there's
just so much variety when it comes to it
and there's just so many items that you
can use here anyway after that sort of
main section of the building is complete
that is by the way not what the roof is
going to look like that this is really
sort of just the beyond the structure
underneath and I'll place the actual
roof tiles or shingles on top of this
later but yeah after that whole section
is done and decided to add one wing of
the building and also some big cross
beams alongside the roof as well which
is a bit overdoing it I'm gonna be
honest this is way too much wood I
honestly could have been fine with the
structure as it was but I just find that
these beams underneath the roof holding
up these large eaves that overhang the
the building and give enough space for
the balcony underneath it as well these
are just such a typical characteristic
touch of Alpine architecture in Europe
that I really wanted to do something
like that as well but then of course
also a big balcony right underneath it
to create this this very inviting
entrance I hope or at least I hope it's
inviting that was the idea behind
building it like this anyway
and that is really going to be them the
main section of the building where most
of the weight is going to be and I'm
just going to build some asymmetrical
wings on both sides a little bit lower
just a ground floor to round off the the
entire restaurant layouts now you can
probably say at this point but itself
why are you doing all of this I mean
you're not even gonna see the majority
of these beams why would you even build
all of them isn't that kind of a waste
of the games
well actually I'm definitely sacrificing
the game performance here as well but
yeah I kind of agree it's a little bit
pointless but for some reason just the
idea that underneath this building is an
actual realistic
roof support structure just kind of
makes it feel a bit more real it's also
fun to just build it got to be honest I
kind of did this more for the process
than the actual final results but even
then I think it makes sense when it
comes to the detailing because on the
edge of the roof you can see all of the
different rafters sticking out and
showing that there is some kind of
wooden you know support structure inside
the building in the front you can see
all of the the gable pieces coming
together and reflecting the the
structure of the entire building so oh I
know I think it makes the whole building
a bit more believable it just forces me
to place all the beams in a way that
would make sense and not just as a
detailing method in hindsight because
normally what I do is just build
buildings that aren't really
structurally sound and add all these
wooden things as
details after I'm done placing the walls
and the roof itself which works more or
less but this method of doing things is
a tiny bit more realistic although it
takes a lot more effort at the end of
the day and in a similar sense I really
like building walls not out of wall
pieces but out of these window pieces
and I'm honestly so glad that frontier
decided to add actual plaster pieces the
planet to because it makes a huge
difference in terms of how easy it is to
you know make custom walls like this but
at the end of the day for the texture it
doesn't actually matter that much
because these window pieces are perfect
for blaster and some people even build
entire builds out of it I'm thinking of
Teleco by free the bear and adver TV
right here also known as Shawn Macbeth
nowadays by the way this is the most
random shout out of all time but I'm
gonna just link that series in the
description because it's absolutely
amazing but it's still not continued
they've been working on it for years and
I think the project is a little bit dead
at the moment but it's one of my
all-time favorites planet coaster builds
it's really amazing and maybe but this
is a very big maybe I could get free the
bear to give me the park file at some
point and see if there's anything I can
do with it but yeah that's that's all
just very very far future kind of
assumptions anyway talika was amazing
and it's a big inspiration and I think
it was one of the forerunners in this
hole creating walls out of window pieces
thing that's people like to do in Planet
goes through although of course Teleco
took it way too far I'm only just using
the balls here and there where the in
game was you know don't really work out
then I'll resort to a few window pieces
but insul eCos case I think almost all
of the buildings are entirely made out
of it but it's cool it definitely allows
for a lot of flexibility and different
shapes and sizes and such
now what you might also notice about
this building is that I'm using these
window pieces to create really big
windows on the building itself just
because I feel like just like the
building at the in the valley the upper
ski building this is also a rather
recent construction it's just built in a
very traditional style to fit with the
ski resort and just well look attractive
there's no reason that a new building
can't be built in an older style of
course but yeah given the fact that the
windows and everything are so large it's
definitely quite a modern influenced
building as well or contemporary I
should say it's always interesting to
kind of come back to this discussion of
whether you should build modern things
or modern architecture or traditional
architecture and I'm using modern here
in the sort of wide sense of you know
newer styles that break away from
vernacular architecture but at the end
of the day I think there's a right time
in place for either of them and
personally I just really like the
aesthetic of restaurants like this
having traditional architecture
especially since traditional European
Swiss Chalet style architecture is very
over-the-top it's it's very sort of
bringing back older architectural styles
so it's actually not really that
authentic but it's just a fun sort of
very ridiculously detailed kind of
cheesy kitschy but wholesome
architectural style that I think is
great for this kind of thing but then
when it comes to ski lift stations or
things like that I honestly really love
contemporary architecture as well for me
personally there's a right time in place
and context for everything and
especially when it comes to architecture
context for me is key there's not really
for me such a thing as as good or bad
architecture per se and you really just
have to look at every building in terms
of you know what its surrounding is like
what the function of it is etc sorry if
that got a little bit too political but
I don't know I guess it's vaguely
relevant to I'm building here by the way
I have to say I'm not actually going to
do any interiors on this I'm already
famous
bad at doing interiors and maybe at some
point in the future I could work on the
insides of this building but for now I
would rather spend my time on you know
finishing the rest of the ski resorts
and you know spending my time on other
things than just being stuck to this one
building here now there came a time in
the time-lapse here where I wasn't
really sure what to do every now and
then so there are some cuts here it's
just me figuring out what my next steps
were going to be but soon enough I
realized that if I want this thing to
actually look realistic and look like an
actual restaurant in a ski resort it has
to have a bunch of mess around it so
there are some big wrecks with skis in
it that honestly I just stole from the
Empress key bar in the valley of the
mountain and some picnic tables right in
front of this building just to make sure
that you know if we can actually sit
down in front of it as well and for a
while I've been considering whether I
want to add parasols to this Terrace as
well I'm still not sure because I think
realistically it's something that you
might see but then again I do like the
view of the building that you have right
now as well so for the time being I'm
gonna keep them open like this but I may
very well add parasols to them at some
point but then again I'm also just kind
of thinking it's a ski resort and if
anything you want to sit in the Sun
whenever it's sunny so doesn't really
make sense in this kind of context and
it's something that while I do see it in
real life I would personally just always
go for a sunny spot if I'm gonna sit
outside at all but then again I am
totally an indoor eater when it comes to
skiing I don't know I think everybody
has that kind of preferences for this
but personally I always like warming up
indoors and taking out taking off all of
my heavy skiing clothes and just
relaxing like that and before I forgot
because I almost did I decided to add
some snow on top of the roof as well
because realistically there is snow on
top of the roofs throughout this build
and there's snow on the trees as well so
a small layer of snow is of course
something that I should add here and
before I finish this episode there was
one more thing that I wanted to do
and then his work on the detailing of
the the poem I left here or as I call it
in the last episode the button lifts
there was a little bit of confusion
about that in the comments because I
didn't really go too much into detail
when it comes to what these things are
like but it's basically just a round
disc of rubber at the end of a stick and
that's why it's called a button because
it kind of looks like a button you stick
that thing between your butts I've
talked about this now it's getting a bit
weird you know the whole like sticking
rubber things up your butt thing but you
know that's that's how you go up a
mountain in this case anyway that's the
that's the lift I'm gonna refer to it in
as a poem if it's in the future I guess
because it really is specifically a lift
by the manufacturer palma but anyway i
wanted to add a bit of detailing to this
and a small fence that protects the the
people on the lift from the people
outside the lift who might crash into
them
you never know it's not actually that
important and you don't always see it in
real life but it's something I figured
was worth adding and also before I
finish that I wanted to add a small
cabin just for whoever's operating the
lifts and I'm not sure what it's like
for these kind of lifts I've never
actually been on a poem I lift myself
all of the similar lifts that I've been
on were by the manufacturer Doble Meyer
which is the same manufacturer for the
gondolas and chair lifts that we have in
the game at least judging by what they
look like but yeah I don't know if this
manufacturer usually adds they're
they're sort of cabins there they're
operator Hut's
on the top or the bottom of the lift but
in this case I just decided to add it up
here because I felt it would look a bit
better and for the style of this
building I'm basically creating the same
kingpost roofs but then on a smaller
scale so it's very similar to the
restaurant building but just a tiny
version of it's basically once again I
kind of feel I didn't really need to go
that far but at this point I just had
too much fun with these things I'm not
sure if you can expect me to go back to
this method of doing roofs I'm probably
gonna scale it down a little bit but
it's good to have it in mind and
know what the actual structure of a roof
is like because it can really help to
make your roofs look better more
realistic and more detailed so for
anyone who's interested I'm also going
to link honestly whenever a kind of
resource I can find down in the
description about these kinds of roofs
so you can learn and teach yourself
about how to build the cool wooden roofs
anyway that is just about it for this
episode so I'd like to thank you guys
for watching and I hope to see you in
the next one I have no idea what I'm
gonna be doing but it'll probably be
something skiing related bye guys
[Music]
you